[Music]
welcome back to cbs mornings we have
more now in the conviction of delane
maxwell and what it could mean for
authorities trying to unravel jeffrey
epstein's sexual trafficking ring in
2018 miami herald investigative reporter
julie k brown uncovered new information
on epstein and maxwell's relationship
and activities she's the author of
perversion of justice the jeffrey
epstein story julie k brown joins us now
julie good to see you again good morning
good morning
so julie your reporting on jeffrey
epstein led to a larger investigation
and eventually brought us to yesterday's
guilty verdict you were in the courtroom
what were you thinking as you heard
the jury's verdicts
i think we were first of all we were a
little surprised because earlier in the
day that jury had indicated that they
still
uh were deliberating in earnest and in
fact they
brought up the topic of maybe
deliberating through the holiday weekend
they had also asked for some more
testimony so it was sort of sudden we
did not expect that it was going to
happen yesterday
and what was it like in the courtroom i
mean how did delane maxwell react what
was the audience reaction i know it was
probably full of reporters
it was full of reporters it was filled
with
u.s marshals who lined the walls behind
us it was
kind of ominous of what was to happen
the jury filed in they appeared very
tired uh you know they had been
deliberating uh 40 hours in total over
six days uh maxwell really didn't show
any reaction she she was she was shaken
as the verdict was read you could tell
because she almost kind of fell over she
wobbled a little bit and then when uh
you know the guilty verdicts were read
she just looked straight ahead and
really didn't show much emotion at all
finally sat down took a sip of water and
just slumped in her chair and
you know as i said she she just appeared
pretty stoic i think she was surprised
in so many ways this trial is about the
victims and julie you wrote for almost
15 years victims of jeffrey epstein
and galaine maxwell had been called
prostitutes had been lied to by
prosecutors had been viciously attacked
by defense lawyers and were traumatized
over and over by a system of justice
that catered to the wealthy and
politically connected couple who had
assaulted them as teenagers very
powerful statement there have you been
able to talk to any of the survivors
well i i spoke with a woman who had been
attending the trial almost every day
this this woman has been taking a
greyhound bus every morning from
philadelphia uh two hours in the morning
uh walking in the cold waiting in line
to get in
um it was
extraordinary and she sat and watched
this almost every day and she felt that
it gave her a sense of closure that she
could finally look uh maxwell in the eye
and feel like you don't you know you're
going to
you know you're not going to control my
life anymore i'm going to get past
julie speaking of those survivors um one
of the alleged survivors virginia dufres
she tweeted out maxwell did not act
alone others must be held accountable
where do things go from here
well she's absolutely right and uh she's
she's not alone in that feeling
epstein did not do this alone there were
many people that helped him he had a
whole ecosystem of people around him uh
the issue here is this case was a
challenge because these events happened
15 20 years ago
and you know memories fade the defense i
think
did a good job at poking holes in some
of the testimony because you know there
were dates that that weren't accurate
because you don't remember everything
exactly the same way when it happened so
long ago so this will pose a challenge
in any future
prosecutions
julie k brown thank you for being here
and thank you for your reporting